did you know that this is not Bulma
briefs and this is not trunks briefs so
how did those of you come to this misund
understanding well it's complicated
first bulma's dad's name is in fact Dr
brief the problem is that isn't his last
name it's his first name that's
obviously a bit odd for us over here in
the west where doctors are usually
referred to by their last name but it is
true the same way Bulma is referred to
here as Dr Bulma furthermore in Dragon
Ball having a last name is super rare to
begin with in the original manga run the
sun family is the only family name in
the entire series furthermore instances
of the last name brief in English have
always been a mistake so yeah Bulma has
no last name their whole family is just
a whole big underwear pun Dr briefs
Bulma trunks tights it's it's a whole
thing